people are taking much longer to do
something that they could have done a
much shorter amount of time
because they're distracted they're not
focused they're not together
then it becomes how do you find balance
how do you know yourself how do you get
to self-awareness here's the exercise
here's what I want you to do we're not
just one thing and when we go all in on
one thing were severely neglecting the
other parts of us which makes for an
empty human
rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's up believe nation at 7:00 my one
word is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent adds something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference so let's start your day off
right together grab your coffee and sip
on today's message find the right
balance over to you girl Gopal das in
the world out there today people have a
wrong idea of success people think
success means achievement and people
think success means having all what the
world is promoting to you so the more
you have the more successful you are and
the more happier you are that's a
completely wrong idea of success that
people have now when you are wanting to
achieve and you're wanting to get the
best and you wanting to get there all
the time obviously have to work hard
loads of people are putting in 14 16 18
hours of work not prioritizing their
health not prioritizing their hobbies
not prioritizing their family not
prioritizing their spirituality not
prioritizing their unwinding them saying
how much do you prioritize there's so
many things seeking your attention is
there a risk of people spreading
themselves too thin and how do you
figure that out how do you how do you
fly I don't think so it's a question of
spreading yourself out I think it's a
question of finding the right balance
irritability and lack of satisfaction is
is is an outcome often life out of
balance you know a life out of balance
now it's like it's like when you an
artist is wanting to make a painting or
a pencil sketch and if
he's sharpening the pencil someone comes
in says hey man you're wasting your type
sharpening the pencil but unless I
sharpen the pencil whatever you do is
going to be extremely blunt so if you
even want to be effective at work in a
chain it's better that you be internally
focused if you are not focused and if
you're not internally mentally stable
your output in the workplace is low as
well I'm saying that if you prioritize
those things that mean to you you work
on yourself you work on your internal
self the consequence of that would be
will be super productive and less number
of hours people are taking much longer
to do something that they could have
done a much shorter amount of time
because they're distracted they're not
focused they're not together what you're
saying is very simple but it's not easy
absolutely so let's cut to the chase
sure give it all to our viewers a few
practical solutions to continue to focus
on oneself and not be distracted by the
noise that there are some tactical
strategies number one start taking an
inventory regularly okay don't just go
with the flow if you're not even paying
attention to you if you're not even
cognizant if you're not even identifying
those areas you're not going to work on
them so first identify that I need to
work on this understand that this is a
priority step two is regularly take time
out if you don't take a break you're
simply leading to a breakdown a break is
going to help you get to a break through
but a lack of break is going to get you
to a breakdown if you have ever read the
book the monk who sold his Ferrari it's
a guy who's just working achieving
putting his 200% and gets a cardiac
arrest at a young age in the courtroom
what is it on the part you've achieved
everything and you know massive failure
because you couldn't work on your life
so - it's take a break now you might say
man I'm really busy how am I going to
take a break
which basically means you don't got it
right if you can't take a break you're
leading to a breakdown prioritize that
break so you can achieve a breakthrough
yeah I do break so not easy even me my
life is 150 to 200 sometimes 250 flights
a year exactly that's how much I travel
how do you take a break
learn the art of unwinding on-the-go how
do you do that you have to do it on the
go prioritize it I listen to your
favorite music read your favorite book
eat your favorite food you know
meditate while or you're on the go sit
there
I don't mind yes then learn the art of
cutting off from the surroundings while
you're on you sitting in the car driving
back home you're sitting on a seventeen
hours flight to New York you know what
are you going to do although 17 hours
learn the art of cutting off from the
surroundings and going within for me
balance is a question of self-awareness
I think most people never find balance
in their life because they don't know
what they actually want they don't have
self-awareness you can look at what
balance looks like to somebody else but
you don't want their life you don't want
the same things that they want and so
they might be perfectly in balance and
you try to copy them that's not the path
my favorite example where this is Dwayne
Johnson the rock actor awesome guy when
he's filming he has to work out for
three hours before he goes in films so
if he has to be on set for 9:00 o'clock
he'll wake up at 5:00 go work out for
three hours have a shower then go on set
and so he'll sleep five hours at night
when he's on on film dude because he
needs to get that work out in the
morning that to him is balanced he says
that's a balanced life for me to me
that's ridiculous that sounds crazy that
sounds like the furthest thing from
balance that I could think of I would
much rather prioritize sleep over waking
up so I can get three hours of working
out every day in that sounds crazy to me
and that's great because he found
balance and what works for him
so if you're looking at my schedule or
get work appalled asses schedule or
Dwayne the rock Johnson schedule it
doesn't matter what you have to do is
have the awareness to figure it out for
yourself what do you want I've got Steve
Jobs up here on my wall you might think
of Haman's as his great visionary and
that's that's why he's up here he went
to make a dent in universe that's what I
want to do so I can model that from him
but he's not the father that I want to
be I'm not gonna learn my parenting
skills from him I have my parents up on
the wall in the middle that's why I want
to learn it from and so you could take
pieces from different people they could
be a source of inspiration but know that
you don't want anybody else's life and
so by that very different
that means balance for you looks
different than somebody else because if
you did balance like them that you would
have their life you don't want their
life you want a better version of your
life and so then it becomes how do you
find balance how do you know yourself
how do you get to self-awareness here's
the exercise here's what I want you to
do okay this is worth it I need you to
take one afternoon off
whether that is a weekday weekend
whatever is easier for you one afternoon
off and you say I don't have an
afternoon off to be able to spend time
on this then you don't deserve a better
life like this is the problem you don't
have an afternoon to figure this stuff
out you need to have an afternoon to sit
down and go through this so figure out a
time in your calendar in the next week
one afternoon off spend the first hour
of that afternoon just unwinding just
relaxing whatever it is that helps you
relax if you need to go out for a walk
in nature if you need to meditate on a
rock if you need to just sit down and
grab a cup of coffee to just get rid of
the stress that you are dealing with the
family's stress the personal stress
health stress business stress partner
stress relationship stress whatever
stresses in your life you need to
release it and do the thing that helps
you release it for me walking in in
nature helps sitting out of Starbucks
helps like you need to unwind yourself
for an hour do it listen to music do the
thing then for the rest of the afternoon
you're taking out a piece of paper you
got a notebook with you and you're gonna
think about every aspect of your life
and what you want it to look like your
business your health your relationships
your career like what do you want to
look like what is it what does balance
look like for you not somebody else's
definition what does it look like for
you spend more time with yourself
instead of time of other people's
opinions on what you should be doing so
write down all the different areas and
how you see a perfect day going and a
perfect week going what makes sense for
you write it down
hour by hour where you're spending your
time and then try to live it and listen
you're gonna make some mistakes great
adjust your plan it won't be perfect but
it's a lot closer than what you're doing
right now trying to live Steve Jobs is
balance or go
copal dass's balance or my balance or
Dwayne Johnson's balance will not work
for you you need to live your balance
and so if you need to adjust great then
once a quarter you go for the same
afternoon off you take your break so you
can have your breakthrough
you take your afternoon off you spend
the first hour distressing reconnecting
with yourself just wandering just to let
everything go and be free and then the
rest of the afternoon spending time
thinking about how you want your life to
look connecting with yourself and then
mapping out a schedule because your
success in all of the areas that you
wrote down will be a direct result of
the habits that you are doing on a daily
basis your schedule your actions need to
map to you accomplishing the balance
that you seek so if you spend once a
quarter that afternoon planning and then
the rest of the quarter executing and
then coming back and making adjustments
that will ultimately allow you to find
the balance that you were seeking and
that is the best fit for you now I've
got a really special bonus clip I think
you're gonna enjoy but before that
question the day I want to know what is
one thing that you need to do to feel
balanced that is little different that
other people don't understand there's a
little outside the box I want you to
release it I want to know what it is I'm
curious share down the comments below
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso and
enjoy the bonus clip
I spray so give me
work life balance is a very personal
thing you know they're guys who work
twelve hours 18 hours a day and think
that they've got balance then others who
work six hours a day and they think
they've got balance so I don't know how
you define it for yourself but for me
work-life balance requires I guess a
couple of things to happen when is we're
going to enjoy what you're doing
you really have to it's really really
critical and if you don't enjoy what
you're doing it's time to do something
different and that's part of the reasons
why I've changed what I did over the
years because if you're going to work as
hard as we work and I travel probably
2/3 of the time and if you're not going
to enjoy what you're doing when you
travel why the hell are you doing it and
so work-life balance starts with
enjoying what you do really well at the
same time you've got to have time for
yourself and the people who matter to
you I mean but I mean you know not just
helping either team move into a dorm
room in Harvard which by the way was up
for bloody flights of stairs with no
elevator with a room partner who had a
stupid shipping trunk that was bigger
than my car that actually carried up the
stairs and I used to call that the two
advil evenings right you kind of had
them and then you had two advil so you
could wake up in the morning without a
broken back here but that you've got to
provide time for that you've got to
provide time for their for their their
play with their acting in it on the
small part that's third tree from left
because it's important to them and so if
you're not going to be there when they
need you then you've got no balance so I
mean I was living in Hong Kong for a
little while running Citigroup in Asia
and I used to fly back from Hong Kong
for one evening to be able to spend the
time that was required if one of them or
ritto were doing something that was
important to us as a family so I guess
you got to enjoy what you're doing but
you've also got to take out the time for
the people who matter to you and when
you're with somebody spend the time with
the person you know this stupid habit of
having a Blackberry or an iPhone in your
hand all the time honestly you're not
spending time with the people you're
with you're spending time with the
instrument and the instrument isn't your
work-life balance it's actually in some
ways an invasion on your work-life
balance
it's useful don't get me wrong I use the
done thing all the time but it's an
invasion if you're not careful so
finding the right space that says when
I'm with you I'm focused on you you
matter to me
and I'm going to spend time with you as
compared to I'm doing that but also
doing this looking at my email doing
phone calls taking our paper working on
the weekends you've got to you've got to
figure out how to find that balance
that's what work-life balance is the
rest all kind of works out so you've got
this I really like the titles I really
want to go after it I'm way intense I
want to win I'm all in getting in that
kind of shape is brutally difficult but
then at the same time you can balance it
with the playfulness and it's not all
about that how have you learned to
strike that balance and and maybe more
importantly how do you teach other
people to do that mmm I've learned if I
don't learn to strike that balance that
when I go to extreme in either one I'm
not I I'm not happy I feel very
scattered I feel frantic I feel crazy so
I think that for me when I start feeling
a little bit chaotic so for me it shows
up in a very like grasping for straws
things aren't happening like I'm running
into a wall like the feeling of banging
your head against a wall that's what it
feels like for me and I know a lot of
people can relate to that and I think
especially a lot of people in fitness
might get into it to kind of like maybe
they're anxious or it calms their nerves
because I think I run really on the
anxious side so for me if I don't learn
how to control that I'll go to the
extreme of something so it's a must for
me I actually think it's a must for
everyone to kind of find how to dance in
the different categories of your life
because we're not just one thing and
when we go all in on one thing were
severely neglecting the other parts of
us which makes for an empty human you
know which makes for someone who doesn't
feel who never feels full so I have to
remember that there's so many parts of
me that I need to make sure that I'm
fulfilling
thick world domination honey Empire
right I'm grateful I understand why I'm
here I think because I am so open I
wanted to think unseen
it's a bloody brief life all of you have
the potential for enormous success if
you want to know what gary vee DJ khalid
oprah and others know about empire
building that most people miss check out
the link in the description for a free
bonus video